نعمة فوسكو 73 في الصورة هنا
أمهات لعائلة إيطالية كبيرة جيرسي جديدة
توفيت يوم الأربعاء بشكل مروّع ولكن قبل
وفاتها
توفي اثنان من أطفالها الأكبر
،
والآن تبع أربعة أطفال آخرين بعد إصابتهم بالفيروس التاجي
في المستشفى ، ما يقرب من 20
من الأقارب الآخرين
في الحجر الصحي ، هل يمكنك ذلك  تخيل
أنني تحدثت إلى اثنين من أفراد الأسرة
روزان باراديسو فوديرا وإليزابيث فوسكو
،
حسنًا ، انظروا أول الأشياء هنا أولاً ،
آه ، يجب أن أخبركم إليزابيث
وروزان أه
هذه مقابلة أتمنى
ألا أفعلها أبدًا
أه عائلتك كل شيء  سماع
ذلك يذكرني
كثيرًا بنفسي ، ورؤية عائلة واحدة تضرب بهذه
الطريقة بشيء
مثل هذا أمر مفجع حقًا ،
يرجى قبول تعازيّ ، أنا
آسف جدًا لخسارتك ووردت
خسارتك أيضًا والعائلة بأكملها من
فضلك
مرحبًا بأنك الآن ، روزان ، كنت تحاول
تجميعها معًا من أجل العائلة والتحدث
إلى الناس ،
آه أولاً ، ما هو هذا بالنسبة لك ،
أعلم أنك في  المحامي وأحيانًا
يقول الناس إنك مثلك محاميًا
كهذا يعني أن لديك نوعًا من
رداء
يمكنك ارتدائه ولا تشعر بكل
شيء يحدث كيف حالك
كيف تفعل الأسرة أن عائلتنا
حزينة جدًا على كل فوسكو
لم يتوقع أحد من قبل أن يتم هلاك عائلة مكونة من 11
طفلاً
مثل هذا ، لذا
فهي بيئة سريالية
على المستوى العاطفي ، أحاول أن
أكون
محامي الأسرة الذي طالما حاولت أن
أكون من أجلهم جميعًا فيما يتعلق بما
تعامل الأسرة معك فقد
أه أربعة أفراد مهمين من
العائلة موجودون بالفعل في الأم ولا
يزال لديك الكثير من الأشخاص في
طريق الأذى لأنني أفهم ما هو
الوضع الحالي
هم بالتأكيد لديهم شخصان
اثنان من الأشقاء إليزابيث  الأشقاء
في حالة خطيرة على أجهزة الإنعاش
في نفس المستشفى التي كانت والدتها
وشقيقها وإخوتها لديها
أخت إضافية في
حالة مستقرة لذلك نحن ممتنون لذلك
لدينا  لقد قطعنا شوطًا طويلاً لنقطعه ، حيث أن
أكبر مخاوفنا بالنسبة للعائلة الآن
هو أن هناك 19 فردًا من العائلة تم
اختبارهم يوم السبت
الماضي وليس لديهم نتائج ، أعني أن
القلق الأكبر
كما قالت روزان مع هذه الاختبارات
ليس
أننا نريد فقط النتائج لتخفيف  أذهاننا
ولكن لدينا أخت تعمل على أجهزة دعم الحياة
لا تعرف أن الأطباء لا يعرفون
ما إذا كانت
إيجابية وكيف يعالجون شخصًا ما
إذا لم يكن
لديهم اختبارات